-White House press secretary,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
holds a lot of press briefings,
but I don't think they asked
all of the questions
we need answers to,
so we decided
to hold another one
right here, right now.
That's right --
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night
White House Press Briefing."
♪♪
Secretary Sanders!
Secretary sanders!
Yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers --
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
I heard Robert Mueller's
investigation is almost done,
What is the administration
doing to get ready?
-We are preparing to leave
tonight for Switzerland.
[ Laughter ]
-What did you always
give Steve Bannon
before talking to him
face to face?
-Additional Scope.
[ Laughter ]
-What was Donald Trump doing
on a boat with Stormy Daniels?
-Offshore drilling.
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-What are Trump's thoughts
on marriage?
-It's temporary.
It's not meant to be permanent.
[ Laughter ]
-What do men use Viagra for?
-Growing their business.
-What does Melania want
for her birthday?
-A small taste of freedom.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
-If Melania ever does
try to escape,
will she have to do it
on her own?
-I'm sure she --
If she decides to run,
which I think the President
states he doesn't feel she will,
I'm sure she'll have help
with that.
[ Laughter ]
-Secretary Sanders,
I have a few questions
about the President's health.
Can you send out the doctor
who performed his physical?
-Thank you.
[ Clears throat ]
Dr. Jackson, I heard
that before his exam,
the President got
so scared of the needles,
he climbed on top
of the cabinets.
What did you tell the orderlies?
-You leave him up there
until he's ready.
How many vegetables
does the President eat?
-One milligram daily.
[ Laughter ]
What were the results
of his brain scan?
-There's no indication
whatsoever that he has any.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-On a scale of 1 to 10,
how dumb is the President?
-30.
-Okay.
What happens when the President
is a good boy?
-He can watch as much TV
as he wants.
-You said that Trump got
a 30 out of 30
on the cognitive test.
Does anyone else you know
ever scored that high?
-My 5-year-old.
[ Laughter ]
What did you say to yourself
after you saw the President
with his shirt off?
-I think I need a drink.
-All right. Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Can you send Secretary Sanders
back out here?
Yes, Secretary Sanders,
what do you do
when you're at a party
on Capitol Hill
and the deejay drops a banger?
-We encourage the Senate
to bring it to the floor.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you think
about Jeff Sessions' eyes?
-I don't think
they're that far apart.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
How does Trump feel about
getting Eric in the divorce?
-The President still
strongly believes
this is one of the worst deals
of all time.
-When I came
into the parking lot today,
I saw you sitting on a Harley,
smoking a cigarette,
blasting Van Halen.
Why?
-Because I'm awesome.
-Okay.
-If you came up
with a new wedding dance,
like the Electric Slide
or Macarena,
what would you call it?
-The Trump Bump.
-All right.
Well, it looks like
we're out of time.
So on behalf of the rest of the
press corps, have a good night!
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."